hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others
and I see we have a variety of questions
saved up where should I start
um
let's see I noticed one from Gil here
uh is it possible to produce large
amounts of crude oil artificially by
manipulating chemical kinetics
Okay so
what is crude oil crude oil is these uh
these is these chains of molecule chains
of carbon atoms with hydrogens connected
to them in molecules and the basic point
is that and and um not necessarily
chains also rings and so on basic point
is that energy is being stored in these
chemical bonds so so roughly what's
going on we've got a bunch of atoms
carbon atoms and those carbon atoms are
are they have forces of attraction
between them which we can think of as
chemical bonds those forces of
attraction come from various effects
mostly kind of complicated physics
effects associated with quantum
mechanics but the end result is that we
can think of like two carbon atoms one
to be stuck together
um because they kind of share electrons
between them
and
what happens in something like oil is
that you've got these some uh these
carbon atoms are arranged in a in a with
a collection of these of bonds in which
there's sort of energy stored in these
bonds so if you were to the if you broke
the um the the this this molecule apart
you would release energy okay where did
this all how did let me let me try and
uh describe how this all started I mean
where does oil come from it is the
results of plants that were growing in
the Carboniferous period whatever for
300 million years ago maybe
um and uh that were uh where rock formed
on top of that sediments got got piled
up on top of that or lava came out on on
top of that and so on and it was it was
uh there was sort of a a big uh pile of
plant material rail that was crushed and
that's the oil that we drill out today
now why is there energy there well
there's energy there because plants have
this whole mechanism all living
organisms have these mechanisms for
getting energy that they can use for
their own operations so to speak and the
energy ultimately comes from the Sun but
it is sort of set up as something that
is stored chemically inside the plant or
or
um and and the way that works is
um
the plant
uses photosynthesis uses this process of
taking uh light from the sun into these
little little things inside uh cells and
and plants called chloroplasts that um
uh have a substance called chlorophyll
in them and through processes that are
still not completely well understood a
photon of light comes in and it causes
the um uh it causes the essentially the
the
um
in the end it's going to cause chemicals
to be produced that uh have energy that
came from that Photon of light from the
Sun but that energy is now kind of
trapped inside the chemical bonds that
exist in these chemicals and those are
ultimately the chemicals that
turned into turn into the oil that we
have today so essentially what we what
we're saying is that we're we're using
energy ultimately from the Sun to put
together these molecules which contain
which have sort of energy stored in them
and when we come to use the oil and we
for example burn the oil
um we are that process of burning adding
oxygen and so on
um releases the energy associated with
those chemical bonds and that's how we
get energy from things like oil
now the question is can we just make
those uh
uh can we just make those molecules
ourselves and the answer is absolutely
yes but it's going to take us energy to
make those molecules because in the end
those molecules are storing energy that
we put into them so yes absolutely we
can make molecules that are just like
crude oil but uh it will it will cost us
energy to do it and then all that will
happen is we'll get that energy back out
again now you can say well well you know
could we at least use that as a way to
store energy and the answer is well yes
in principle
um we're not particularly efficient I
think at doing
um the the chemistry to uh to store
energy I mean chloroplasts and plants
are very efficient at taking light from
the sun and turning it into chemical
energy we don't have a sufficient a way
to do it
um and so it's kind of like well might
as well use the plants for around 300
million years to ago to do it
one can imagine in terms of taking
energy that comes from from light from
the sun and turning it into other forms
of energy that are more useful to us for
example photovoltaic cells solar cells
are doing exactly that that kind of
thing they're turning light from the sun
into electrical energy which we can then
potentially store in a battery battery
is using electrochemistry to kind of
store energy so that we can use it again
later
so I think the um
uh
that's
um now the question of what
the actual molecules that you get in uh
in something like crude oil alike that's
a somewhat complicated story you know if
you go to a gas pump like in the U.S
you'll see that it says something like
oh gosh I proved I don't don't fill up
my car with gas often enough but things
like 95 octane will be a sort of thing
written on a pump and that is a
representation of the size and structure
of the molecules that are in the oil
that that are in the gasoline that you
might be putting in your in your car and
I think I think on most um most gas
pumps in the US they kind of have a
footnote that says you know it says 95
octane or something and then it says
footnote using the r plus M over 2
method I think that's what they say and
that that's a way of of uh answering the
question what does that 95 actually mean
and the uh in this it's a question how
big is the molecule how many rings does
it have in it how much how much how many
kind of uh sort of compact bonds does
are there in that molecule that store
energy that your car could potentially
use to to run off
now it turns out that when
um
this oil was formed
okay I I'm I'm sort of Miss I missed a
piece of that story when the oil is
formed there is it starts with the
plants but then there is uh how does
this work
there's
a chemical process that causes
one to get
different sizes of molecules depending
on the precise conditions and pressure
and temperature and so on at which this
oil was formed and I know what happens
is that in different parts of the world
there are oil reserves that are you know
underground in different places famous
one is West Texas oil reserves there are
ones in Saudi Arabia places like that
but the question is what is the
distribution of sizes of molecules that
exist in these different oil reserves
and I believe the the sort of famous
kind of oil is West Texas intermediate I
think it's called and that particular
kind of oil has kind of a a good mixture
of different sizes of molecules in it
from ones that are really long molecules
that are suitable for things like making
Plastics and tar and things like that to
ones that are really short molecules
that are suitable I guess for aviation
fuel and things like this
and I think that the um uh
um so in different places different
conditions caused the details of the oil
molecules that were produced to be
somewhat different and that has an
effect on what uh what kind of thing the
oil that's pumped out from the ground in
different places can be used for
um and and typically there's a a process
fractional distillation where you take
the the raw oil that's been pumped out
of the ground and you have a kind of
column that uh this that that
um breaks down oil that the stuff that
sort of goes higher in the column is the
lighter oil and that's the the one with
smaller molecules the one with larger
molecules stay stay lower down in the
column and that's how you kind of can
get uh can break apart these things that
are useful for cars and planes and and
making Plastics and things like this
so uh I thought that was going to be a
simpler question to answer that that's
an attempt to answer the um
this question of um uh of kind of how
how oil sort of the chemistry of what's
happening with oil I mean there are all
kinds of things I can imagine you know
can you imagine could you make a
bacterium that would make oil just like
you can have bacteria that um uh have uh
genetic specifications that that um so
so
basically what biological organisms do
is their genomes specify how to make
proteins proteins are sequences of amino
acids amino acids have nothing to do
with oil as such so if you want to have
an organism make uh make something like
oil you have to do it as a kind of
secondary thing you can't have it
directly make you know what organisms
directly make is just things that are
proteins but proteins can do things like
for example they can have you could have
a a collection of of um
uh you can have a protein that folds
itself up and makes a little cage and a
cage which is of just the right size to
fit a particular kind of atom like for
example in hemoglobin
um that's used to transport oxygen in
our blood
um the uh
the protein that that is hemoglobin has
a cage which is just the right size to
fit a single iron atom inside and that
that iron atom there's enough kind of
random iron atoms lying around that
there'll be an iron atom that Finds Its
way into that cage that gets trapped
there and that's what gets used in the
um uh in the red blood cell and same
thing for I don't know
the thyroid gland for example well no
what is it vitamin vitamin B12
um is sometimes called cabalamine it has
a um it has a Cobalt atom in the middle
that gets trapped in the middle of its
protein and I suppose one can imagine
some mechanism for having the sort of
the right molecular shape to be able to
sort of assemble
um an oil molecule so to speak uh uh by
something that has been well once
constructed the molecule using sort of a
biological process to specify what the
shape of the molecule should be nobody's
successfully managed to do that I think
people have tried and it tends to be the
case that whenever you can make
something sort of oil like it kills the
um the organism that uh that was making
it because it doesn't really like being
in an environment that where it's sort
of drowning in oil and so on
um
so I think uh a few thoughts about that
um
let's see
uh
well
Zayden asks how is the distance to a
distance to a distant Galaxy determined
well okay so
first the
the main way that that that's done is by
using the fact that the universe is
expanding and so galaxies that are
further away are moving away from us at
higher speeds so here's a way to think
about it imagine that you've got a bunch
of uh kind of
um you've got a a um a balloon let's say
and on the surface of the balloon you've
put a bunch of dots
and then you start inflating the balloon
and the whole surface will get bigger
and the dots will move away from each
other if you sit yourself at one of the
dots and you ask the question how fast
will a DOT
further away from you be moving away
what you should find is that uh the the
distance that that dot further away from
you is moving away let's see let's see
how to think about this the the um
uh
the way to think about this is let's say
you've doubled the size of the balloon
then the uh let's think about this
um the the basic point is that
the universe is expanding and
we can talk about why the universe is
expanding that's a separate question but
the universe is expanding and it has
that and it's expanding uniformly in all
parts of the universe and that has the
effect that a Galaxy that's further away
the speed with which it's receding from
us will increase with the distance away
that that Galaxy is
so take take that as a given for now now
ask the question how do we tell what
speed a galaxy is is moving away from us
at and the answer is we use this thing
called the Doppler shift and here's how
this works the once heard you know if
you if you hear a a siren or something
you'll hear it as it comes towards you
the siren will be higher pitched as it
goes away from you it will be lower
pitched why is that essentially it's
because if you think about the sound
wave that is the the sound of the siren
so if the if there's just a fixed
frequency if it's just sort of if it was
a if it was a siren that was just
playing one note then
what it would what it would have is a
series of compression expansion
compression expansion
um pieces to a sound wave and normally
those compression expansion Etc pieces
move at the speed of sound so you're
you're hearing uh a compression piece of
compression followed by a piece of
expansion followed by a piece of
compression and those things are
arriving at your ear at the speed of
sound
well what happens is if the thing that
is producing those sounds is it's
self-moving then what will happen is
that the the for example let's say it's
moving towards you then those those sort
of uh expansion compression expansion
and so on peace says will be squashed
closer together because they are
um because each one of them
they're all sort of coming out they're
all moving at the speed of sound but the
thing that is producing them is itself
moving and so they they haven't they
they sort of they're all escaping at the
speed of sound but the thing that's
producing them keeps on putting keeps on
getting closer to you and sort of
inserting a new picotroph in the wave uh
at a shorter distance than it would do
if it was just moving purely at the
speed of sound so what ends up happening
is that when the when the object that's
producing the sound is moving towards
you the frequency of the sound the
distance between uh the Peaks and
troughs of the wave is smaller and so
you hear a higher pitched sound and when
it's moving away from you the opposite
happens you see a lot hear a lower sound
so you can kind of uh you could figure
out the speed that something was moving
at for example by telling what the
change of frequency was of the sound
that it was producing
okay so the same thing happens with
light
it's a little trickier because with
light uh unlike with sound the the speed
of light is is constant this is a
feature this is kind of the one of the
main claims of Relativity theory is that
the the speed of light doesn't depend on
uh there isn't a a um uh in the case of
sound sound is moving through air
and the air is stationary and if you're
moving relative to that then the the uh
they're still fixed air in which sound
moves at a certain speed and the claim
is that that's not what happens with
light
um and so this this dopplership
phenomenon is a little bit more subtle
in the case of light but the same basic
thing happens when something is moving
towards you the frequency is higher of
the light when it's going away from you
the frequency is is made lower so that
means if you have
um like visible light
the the if you look at
um
you look at different colors of light
red light has a lower frequency it has a
longer wavelength
blue light has a higher frequency a
shorter a a shorter wavelength and so
what happens is what you might start off
with as let's say white light which is a
mixture of all frequencies you will
shift that down to be uh on average
redder if the thing is that is emitting
the light is moving away from you and
it'll be Bluer if the thing that's
that's emitting the light is moving
towards you
so what happens is that galaxies will
are emitting light and when the Galaxy
is moving away from us it will be the
light from it will be redshifted and
that
um uh by the stopler effect and the
amount of the redshift depends on the
speed that it's going at
so in the way that um these things are
usually described you talk about a red
shift it's usually denoted Z and that's
a redshift of Two and a redshift of two
means that the frequency of light that
we're getting from that Galaxy is half
the way that that what we would get if
if that Galaxy were just at rest
right next to us as opposed to moving
away from us
so that what one does to estimate the
distance to a distant Galaxy is mostly
look at the redshift of the light that
comes from that Galaxy important point
about this the uh
when when you get light from a Galaxy
for example
um
some of that light
is light at very fixed frequencies so
okay you make an object hot at a certain
temperature it will it will get first
red hot then white hot then blue hot and
so on it will have a range of
frequencies that it emits just by virtue
of being a hot object
that isn't so useful in looking at the
stopless shift because you have to kind
of know how how hot is the object and to
know is it how redshifted is it or not
it could just be the object was colder
and that's why it was redder it wasn't
redder because it was moving away from
you at a high speed
but there are things that are a very
fixed frequency and those are Atomic
transition lines and so what those are
are when you have an atom that has
electrons you have a nucleus of the atom
you have electrons in the atom and when
the way that quantum mechanics works
the electrons in the atom can't just
have any energy they want they can't be
it's it's as if so the electrons are
kind of orbiting the nucleus and it
could be the case that they kind of
orbit at any distance and they can have
any amount of of kinetic energy
associated with orbiting at that
distance so you know if you have planets
orbiting a star or something you kind of
imagine that the planets can orbit at
any distance from the Star and depending
on what the distance from the star is
they'll have different amounts of
kinetic energy associated with the with
the speed that they're going around
their orbits at
but the claim of quantum mechanics says
that's not how things work on the atomic
scale and it isn't the case that the
electrons can have any energy they want
there are just a fixed collection of
possible energies that can exist for the
electrons in in an atom so then what
happens is
that that fixed collection of energy
levels for the atom and if there's a
photon of light
that uh is going to be absorbed by the
atom the way it gets absorbed is it
takes there's an electron in the atom
and that electron can be can absorb the
photon and then it can jump to another
energy level but it can't if that photon
is not of the right frequency to deliver
exactly the right amount of energy to
jump that electron to the energy level
that's sort of there waiting for it to
receive it then that Photon will not get
absorbed by the electron so in order to
be absorbed the photon has to have
exactly the right energy uh to um uh to
make the electron make the transition to
the higher energy energy level and so
that means that the the so-called Atomic
transition line
well okay I can explain why it's called
that but but basically the point is that
for a given atom there will be very
precise numbers there will be very
precise energies of light that can be
absorbed by that atom or can be emitted
by the atom and those precise energies
correspond to particular frequencies of
uh of photons frequencies of light and
so that means that in addition to this
kind of thermal spectrum of just the
thing is hot you'll also see these very
specific spectral lines these very
specific energy levels very specific
colors of light emitted by for example a
star or the material around a star or
something like that
and that's that's the way that one can
determine more precisely uh what the
redshift of a galaxy is by looking at
how a particular spectral line a
particular a particular one of these
transitions
um how what the uh energy frequency
color associated with that transition is
you know as perceived by us in a distant
Galaxy as a pair as opposed to being
perceived by us here now a big
assumption in all of this which is that
a galaxy far far away you know the the
um
the hydrogen atoms and the galaxy far
far away work the same as the hydrogen
atoms for us here but we have many
reasons to believe that that's true and
that you can use kind of the hydrogen
atoms as a kind of standard uh measure
of things like frequencies uh that will
work for any Galaxy
so basically the idea is you look at
those transitions you those particular
fixed energies for example for hydrogen
atoms and you say what's what is our
perceived version of one of those
energies for a distant Galaxy and for
example it might be the case that that
Galaxy it might be I don't know four
times
redshifted which means that the
frequency is four times lower as
perceived by us for that particular
transition in hydrogen in the distant
Galaxy
now in order to get all of this stuff
started one has to know well how far
away are these galaxies in fact
um uh you know it has to have a
normalization we say okay it's redshift
of two but how far away does redshift of
2 correspond to and that's what Edwin
Hubble followed that figured out in the
1920s in the discovery of the expansion
of the Universe
um what what he essentially assumed was
that if you've got a Galaxy the overall
amount of light produced by that Galaxy
is always the same
and or at least on average it's always
the same for a Galaxy there there there
exist galaxies of a certain size well
okay
okay the the assume that you had
identical galaxies but of course there's
a range of different sizes of galaxies
but assuming you had an identical Galaxy
it would produce a certain amount of
light the further away that galaxy is
the less light we will receive from that
Galaxy
so the reason for that is just that the
light from a Galaxy is going off in all
directions and the the further away we
are the fraction of that sphere of all
the directions the light can go in the
fraction of that sphere that is kind of
the the uh our telescope will get
smaller and smaller the further and
further away we go so the intensity of
light from the Galaxy will fall off like
the inverse square of the distance from
the Galaxy roughly and so that's an a
different way of working out what the
distance to the Galaxy is now in um
uh independent of the redshift so what
what Hubble did was to connect redshift
to perceived distance based on
brightness more or less of of galaxies
and to determine that yes it's really
true that the perceived brightness of
galaxies goes down as the redshift goes
up those galaxies are further away and
and then by sort of fitting all those
pieces together one concludes that yes
the universe is more or less uh uh sort
of uniformly expanding now the the uh in
more recent times there are sort of more
precise efforts to know uh what
uh what the distance to a Galaxy is by
by looking at but to to normalize this
this uh connection between redshift and
distance to galaxies and uh there's a
lot of um a lot of effort to try to
calculate the expansion rate of the
universe and so on the characteristics
of the expansion of the universe by
comparing essentially the brightness of
galaxies and the redshift of galaxies
and it gets kind of tricky because one
wants to have sort of a standard candle
that is a thing that's always of the
same brightness in a galaxy but that's a
bit hard to achieve because for example
different galaxies can be different
sizes if you have a supernova an
exploding star you can kind of assume
that uh there will be uh there's a
certain uniformity to the way that it's
exploding Stars work and that that will
be the same in any Galaxy anywhere it's
a little tricky because galaxies that
are sort of made from the from the
rubble of previous or even stars made
from a kind of rubble of previous stars
that have exploded they have somewhat
different elements in them than the
earlier stars because the the process of
going through and making a star and
having it limits you know multi-million
year or billion year life and then
having it explode in the Supernova that
whole process causes uh different
elements different chemical elements to
be made which can then be used in the
next generation of star so there's some
trickiness in figuring out exactly
whether one has kind of the a really
truly comparable uh kind of way of
working out the the brightness of of um
of galaxies and so on but that's the
rough way that one figures these kinds
of things out the thing that has become
clear in recent times it's kind of a
subtle thing just what is the expansion
rate of the universe is the universe
getting progressively faster in its
expansion is it progressively slower and
it's Mansion or is it kind of going to
get to the point where eventually it's
just coasting and its expansion and the
question of what's going to happen one
can try and work out by looking at this
you know what is the actual expansion
rate as measured by looking at distant
galaxies
um one can also work out what will one
expect based on the equations of gravity
and the total amount of matter that one
knows is in the universe and so on and
the the end result here is that there's
some kind of complicated mismatches
between what's observed in the expansion
rate and the amount of matter that seems
to be in the universe and that's what
leads to this idea of dark energy which
is essentially negative Mass matter that
matter that has gravitational repulsion
rather than gravitational attraction one
hasn't explicitly seen it but kind of to
make the calculations work in the
standard theory of gravity one would
have to have some of the Stark energy in
our universe whether that's really how
things work look I'm I'm unconvinced and
I think our physics project probably has
some things to say about this although
it's it's kind of difficult to actually
Trace that through to get to the point
where one has a definite statement to
make but um anyway so a few thoughts on
um uh
on how our measures distant galaxies
uh
let's see
oh my there's a question
uh what industries do you think will be
most disrupted by chat GPT
mid-journey AI applications and so on
um I think I talked about this a little
bit before uh
maybe
um
well
just say a little bit about sort of
what's happened in the kind of current
generation of generative AI
sort of the the big thing of the last
month or so has been chat GPT which is a
text-based generative AI system and uh
also uh you know Dali and mid-journey
and so on are image based generative AI
systems
what do these things do the goal is to
make either text or images that's kind
of like stuff that's
out there on the web or elsewhere
but is stuff that is specifically
responsive to some particular prompt
that's given so in the case of text you
might say so you might have a prompt
where you start off a piece of of text
and then what chat GPT is at some level
trying to do is to complete that piece
of text in a way that is kind of what
one would expect based on what's out
there on the web
so if you say uh you know the best thing
about AI is it's ability to whatever
well let's say the best thing about AI
is it's
and you know it's a good chance the next
World will be ability
and that's we can know that because if
we look through billions of web
documents we'll find that yes the next
word is most often ability for example
and so what chat GPT
for example is doing is it's saying
given some prompt that you gave like
write me an essay about this that and
the other then what it's going to do is
it's going to try and fill in what will
be the what will be the most likely well
what would be a possible completion that
is consistent with the kind of thing
that it's read on the web
and of course it will just make a lot of
stuff up because it it will have read on
the web let's say you ask it some data
about some particular thing in the world
it will have seen that data about that
kind of thing in the world is usually
attributed I don't know the U.S Census
Bureau or something like that so it'll
confidently write down according to the
U.S Census Bureau because that's what it
read from elsewhere the number is blah
blah blah blah but it made that number
up it just was making up a number that
was kind of consistent with what it's
seen elsewhere now of course one could
be lucky and that number could be
something that it explicitly saw the
number for that particular thing the
population of the US is or whatever it
could have seen that particular you
could have seen the sentence the
population of the US is and seen a
number that came after it and it could
have somehow picked that up and be
filling that in and the thing that it's
generating for you
what tends to happen is there's a notion
of a temperature parameter for for these
completion systems which kind of says
how much jiggling around there should be
at the end if the temperature is zero
then what will happen is it will have
some way of working out what's the most
probable next word that will occur and
it just says here's the next word
actually if you do that if you set the
temperature parameter to zero you'll
find even with the fanciest you know
chat GPT GPT 3.5 whatever system that it
often gets itself in a loop it often
starts just it comes up with some words
and then it's just like you know it just
says the cat sat on the mat sat on the
mat sat on the mat sat on the mat Etc et
cetera et cetera it just Loops
um
you if you give it a little bit of
Randomness a little bit of jiggling
it'll not do that and that Randomness
what it's done is it's figured out
what's the most likely next word what's
the second most likely next word what's
a ranking of the likelihoods of
different words and if you don't always
just obstinately pick oh I want the most
probable one each time and the
probability the spread of probabilities
may not be very great and you allow it
to go and you know dig deeper then it
will produce something which is uh does
not have sort of get stuck in loops and
things like this and it ends up sounding
much more human and it has a certain
degree of kind of unexpected creativity
one can call it from the fact that it's
it's just randomly picking between these
different different words and so for
example you know if you regenerate from
the same prompt in chat GPT you'll often
get different results sometimes the only
results it can give you are ones which
corresponded to some some particular set
of things that had seen before that were
responsive to your prompt and however
much you know there's only one thing in
the queue basically that could be pulled
off it's not like there are lots of
things vying for uh for being delivered
as as the next word and one of the
surprising things about something like
Chachi PT is it's ultimately it's
writing you know that big essay that it
wrote that's a very coherent essay was
written one word at a time and what's
happening is each new word that's put
down that becomes sort of a an extended
prompt that's used to figure out well
what should the next word be it's not
thinking to itself it's not kind of
taking a step back and thinking how
should I lay out this whole essay it's
just putting down one word at a time and
it's using the fact that it's seen these
patterns of how how things get put
together
and it's then emulating those patterns
and we could talk a little bit about
what the kind of um uh the deeper idea
of of the emulation of those patterns is
and how one should think about that I'm
not sure I'm not sure it's it's uh it's
it's yet very clear I've thought about
this a little bit myself actually
um and uh
well I can say something about that
okay so so how does something like chat
GPT work
the first thing it does is well it uses
a lot of kind of mathematical numerical
kinds of ideas the first thing it has to
do is it's dealing with words words are
not numbers you have to somehow turn
words into something like numbers and
that's done by using uh so-called
embedding vectors and what's being done
is you take a word and you're going to
turn a word into a list of a thousand
numbers you say the word cat is the
system a thousand numbers the word dog
is another list of a thousand numbers
the word uh oil is another list of a
thousand numbers the word uh jump is
another list of a thousand numbers and
so on and the idea is to make it be the
case that those lists of a thousand
numbers are such that the numbers are
fairly close if the words are close in
meaning and they're far away if the
words are far away meaning and so what's
in order to get those lists of numbers
where you can do that is you can kind of
look at a given word and you can see
where does that word occur in context if
if you see that you can substitute you
can either say
um you know the cat sat on the mat the
dog sat on the mat
they're both something sat on the mat so
to speak and the fact that those two
words can occur often occur in the same
context means that cat and dog are
somehow similar and you can use that
that context to to find the numbers that
you can use to represent these words so
the first step is words are turned into
vectors of numbers collections of
numbers actually it's it's slightly sub
words if the words are long they're
broken into sort of tokens that aren't
the complete word and that's why for
example you'll sometimes see chat GPT
make up a word because it's able to to
it creates these tokens it smooshes the
tokens together and there's a new word
um and um
it does that a bunch when it's trying to
generate a programming language output
and so on but okay so then
uh what happens to that
well
the the ultimate operation of the system
is it's going to you give it a list of a
certain number of tokens that is your
prompt its goal is to add sequentially
one more token another token another
token another token and so on each time
doing it according to kind of what it's
learned from reading the web in a bunch
of books and things like this is the
typical sequence of what token follows
what token follows what token and so on
so
that's sort of a question of
uh okay so how does it actually figure
that out well it has a whole bunch of
layers of what's roughly doing is it has
essential attention layers and what
they're doing is they're saying uh the
token you're about to put down which
previous tokens does it depend on does
it depend on the most recent token does
it depend on the one five steps ago does
it depend on the one 10 steps ago and so
on it has kind of a pattern of of of of
which steps ago does this token depend
on it's kind of like in a sentence in
English you might have a a subordinate
clause you know the the black cat sat on
the uh very dirty mat
and you know the the the the the the cat
and the mat are kind of connected as
things that are kind of uh related to
each other
um the the fact that the cat was black
the fact that the mat was very dirty
those are kind of footnotes to what's
going on and so you really kind of want
in order to determine that you that it's
going to be a mat that you that the
thing is sitting on so to speak it's
gonna and you know the what was it that
was sitting on it well it's going to
jump back many words to find that it was
the cat and the attention layer is all
about kind of figuring out how many
words back you have to look to sort of
know what's going on okay so there's a
the um the the way that um
the system works as it's looking back
it's figuring out which pieces are
important then it's saying okay given
that uh
given
what
uh what was there before what should I
put down next and what's happened is
it's it's sort of figured out
what is the kind of typical average
thing that happens based on having seen
billions trillions of of of characters
of of uh trillions of tokens of text
gotten from the web
and so you can ask the question well it
could be the case that the next token to
put down depends in detail on the
particulars of every token that were
there whether it's a token for a cat for
a token for a dog
etc etc etc that it can depend on the
particulars it could also be the case
that there are some more Global kind of
I've been thinking of them as sort of
semantic Laws of Motion some more Global
way of saying if you've got things that
are sort of that have a collection of
meanings that are sort of uh that that
have this sequence then the thing you
get next is something which is sort of
at this place in meaning space you can
think about these vectors of numbers
that represent the these embedding
vectors for Words as defining points in
space if they're length a thousand uh
vectors it's thousand-dimensional space
which is kind of awkward to deal with we
could think of a very simplified model
that won't give us very good results
where we say oh it's a two-dimensional
space and so you know cat is at this
position dog is at this position and so
on
um and uh you can you can at least make
pictures like that using this technique
called Dimension reduction and like
emotion language you can use features
based plots to make pictures like that
of sort of how words are arranged in
this meaning space
but
so the question is are there sort of
generic features of how one moves around
a meaning space as one moves through a
sentence and so on don't know the answer
to this yet but I kind of suspect that
there are and I kind of suspect that
there are things we haven't ever noticed
before that it kind of patterns of of
how you of how the sentences we form
um end up sort of having pieces that
that have meanings that fit together in
much the same way that when we form a
syntax and we a sentence and we ask
about syntax you know it's subject verb
object and so on
um that there's a definite form for the
grammar of the sentence so also I
suspect there's a definite form to
certain aspects of the the flow of
meaning in a sentence uh but it's more
difficult to understand that and whereas
in grammar one can say oh they're a
nouns there are verbs there are these
kinds of things what exactly the
semantic can categories are the
categories associated with meaning that
one can also sort of put together in
those definite ways I I don't yet know
but I think that that's that's kind of
roughly what's what's happening is that
GPT has kind of learned these um uh
um
these kind of um uh these these um
uh these sort of patterns of of um a
flow of meaning and that that's what
it's really putting down I noticed a a
um uh uh comments here from Christopher
about asking about integrating orphan
Alpha and so I'm a chat CPT yes it's a
very lovely thing
um I'll probably write something about
this very soon
um the uh uh you know wolfen Alpha is a
very different story what it's doing is
very different from what chat GPT is
doing chat GPT is you know it's it's
taken what's on the web it's smooshed it
up it's turned it into something where
it can make stuff that is statistically
similar to the web as a piece of text
well from alpha is doing is it's taking
some piece of natural language input
it's turning it into this precise
symbolic computational language then
it's using sort of precisely set up data
and algorithms and so on to compute the
results from that precise symbolic
computational language
and so you know you ask it what's the
distance from place a to place B on the
earth it knows the coordinates of those
places it computes the great circle
distance and it tells you the result
whereas what chat GPT will be doing for
something like that and it's and is is
saying well you know I've seen something
roughly like that on the web let me let
me kind of extrapolate for what I've
seen on the web and make something which
is statistically similar to what I've
seen on the web and you know that
usually is a four digit number that I
see oh I'll make up that number because
that's how it works and and what it puts
there may be complete nonsense
um you know it's worth realizing you can
ask chatgpt to write fiction you can ask
it to write non-fiction
um you know it you can ask it to write a
persuasive essay about all kinds of
crazy things and it'll make up just
amazing things you know I've I've used
it and I I have to say
um I uh I asked it um I asked it to
write an essay about why uh the wolf a
wolf is the bluest type of animal and it
confidently starts writing about how
well blue wolves are not usually
considered blue but uh there isn't it is
in fact the case that wolves are they
can be very blue wolves and they gave a
Latin name for a possible blue wolf and
it said it lived in the Tibetan plateau
and it was like going on and on about
blue wolves and it had a whole theory
about coloration patterns based on the
way that uh uh well it talked about
structural coloration I didn't look all
this stuff up but I was reading it and
it's like oh okay maybe there is a blue
wolf kind of thing
um and uh I did check a few things and
they're just complete nonsense just
completely made up
which was sort of brilliant on on the
part of chat GPT it is statistically
like what I would expect to see but not
actuality so to speak very different
branch from what you kind of get with
wealth and Alpha where if if Wolfman
Alpha says the answer is this it really
is that because it was able to you know
turn what you asked into something
computational it could compute the
answer get the result gives you the
result now it turns out to be possible
to nip these two things together
actually a very simple way in a sense
you literally ask chat GPT what facts
did you have what questions could be
answered from the essay you just wrote
and it says oh you know what's the color
of this kind of wolf what's the whatever
and then you feed those questions that
it generates into wolf from alpha which
will then either understand the question
and tell you what the correct answer is
or will say I don't understand this
question then you take the results from
that you take those things you feed them
back to chat GPT and it will then
rewrite its essay having corrected the
things that it got wrong
so that's a that's a kind of an example
of a workflow of kind of integrating
sort of precise computational knowledge
with essentially statistical text
Generation
Um that uh that chat GPT is doing and I
think that combination can be quite
powerful it's probably even more
powerful when you're doing that precise
computation on things like data inside a
company and things like this there's
there's all sorts of stuff to to to work
out there but um I think some
interesting things will happen there
I think um
um
it's uh
um
yeah it's kind of it's a
um in chat GPT it's a definitely don't
do your math homework with it it
produces this amazingly convincing
sounding stuff
um this is completely and utterly wrong
um I mean it's not like it's not like oh
the things the things dumb and the
people who built it dumb not at all it's
it's a very wonderful piece of
technology it's just that the thing it's
doing is to make statistically plausible
statements based on what is out there on
the web and other things and it just
turns out that it isn't enough to make
statistically plausible textual
statements that there is there is
something that has been achieved in kind
of the things that we've done in sort of
algorithms and Science and Mathematics
and so on that goes beyond kind of what
you can get by just sort of uh
statistically making up text it's in a
sense that sort of the Divergence that
happened between kind of the the time
when people were mostly talking about
things and and sort of philosophical
textual terms at the time when sort of
formal mathematics got started
particularly from the 1600s and and
there and after that where sort of this
formal more mathematical Tradition now
the computational tradition where one's
really talking about these kind of
precise
uh types of of uh of big towers of of
um a formal structure is rather
different from what you get by just
talking about the the sort of statistics
of text and so on
um
the uh so the question
um I think was also asked about about
um generative images and that's a place
where one is doing the same kind of
thing one wants to make an image that is
so statistically similar to images One
seen before but uh it is generated for
example from a prompt and you associate
textual prompts with images because
there are images with captions on the
web and so on you can kind of uh forage
all of those things
and then you're generating something
which is sort of statistically what you
would expect to be associated with one
of these prompts but you're generating
something which is has never in detail
been seen before but it has the right
kind of texture and and statistics to
correspond to an appropriate image
and so I think the question was which
was asked is is what will be
um the most disrupted by uh these kinds
of Technologies you know I think
one
there's a lot of places where it is
where one wants something
that will attract a person's attention
whether it's an icon to put at the top
of a blog post or something that's some
kind of striking icon that has visuals
that are sort of associated with the
blog post where one might generate that
automatically whether one's got you know
a a uh a card when sending somebody well
it's got an image on the front of the
card well and just wants to have a a
nice interesting emotionally appropriate
image so to speak where the real meat of
the thing is what one says inside for
example similarly women's having text
you know whether it's kind of a an
introduction where one's kind of like uh
high so and so and there's some small
talk so to speak and then maybe there's
a main delivery underneath or even
there's a there's a place where one's
describing something sort of
personalized to a particular individual
and I think you know I'm certainly
expecting that some fraction I I just
learned actually that one thing somebody
sent me at uh uh over the holidays just
now which was a which is a card with a
nice image and text inside it was
completely automatically generated and I
did not know that and I thought boy this
person's gone to an awful lot of trouble
perhaps more trouble than they should
have done to produce this this uh this
card for me and um uh you know in fact
it was completely um
automatically generated but still had
sort of a a a a kind of a a relevant
human message so to speak so I think
this this idea of sort of connect to the
humans
um the uh
um
uh is is a you know this is something
which is these are these are sort of a a
a a a user interface another level of
user interface of things to be
comfortable for for use by humans I know
it was commenting that an automatic
nonsense falsity detector would be an
interesting tool to have yeah well so
some of what one can do with wealth
malfa is you know you ask Chachi PT to
ask you know what are some facts that
you could check in this essay and it'll
split them out and you just feed them
into wealth malpha and Wolfman Alpha may
not know those particular facts it might
be or it might be you know you're
writing a fictional essay and the facts
are something that is completely
fictional and was intended to be
fictional so then what Marvel can't help
you I can't fact check something that is
that is a fictional fact so to speak
um but when it's some actual fact about
the world it'll have a decent chance to
be able to to check that particularly if
it's a a more slightly more quantitative
or definite or formal fact about the
world
um I think you know it certainly quite
uh the the idea of having sort of a a
signature of of AI nests so to speak to
a piece of text that's been produced
well the whole notion of Let's Make
texts that's statistically similar to
text that's already out there kind of
goes against the idea of let's have
something about that text be distinctly
not like the text the humans have
written kind of the the whole idea of
the training of something like chat GPT
is to make human-like text
now you can certainly imagine if
somebody said well you know we want to
make sure that you can tell that the
recipient of the text can tell that's
got a stamp on it that says I was made
by an AI
there's this whole technique of what's
usually called steganography being able
to sort of hide messages and things like
text so a very trivial thing would be
you know you put a different number of
spaces after periods in different parts
of the text you know maybe it's one
space in the after the first period two
spaces off the second period one space
after the third period and so on and
that's something where by pure chance
one wouldn't get one two one two one two
number of spaces off the periods in a
particular document and it's very
unlikely the person would have made the
sort of made the inconsistency of doing
that but you could then pick up you
could detect that particular pattern and
say oh that was AI stamped so to speak
once you know in the case of that
particular pattern once you know the
pattern is there you can obviously fake
it easily enough but there are more
subtle things one can imagine and the
way that that chat GPT works I think
it's quite quite feasible to have
something where you can inject into this
process of picking tokens you can inject
things that at least with with high
probability would be a giveaway that
this was an AI generated thing rather
than something that was uh sort of
direct human so to speak
so I think um uh it's um
it's something where
um you
have um uh you know I'm sure this will
come of people saying no no it's really
you know it's a it's a
you know it's human generated oh it's AI
generator oh it's a human in the loop oh
it's you know many different gradations
of how much humanness there was I mean
it's kind of like you get the AI to
produce something and you look at it
yourself and you say I approved this
message or you say that's one version or
another thing is you write the text
yourself but your English is a little
bit messy and you know your grammar
isn't quite right and then you tell the
AI to clean up your English
uh you know there's there's everything
between those two extremes and probably
more Beyond uh will certainly happen and
be useful and I think you know if you
ask the question what and what will
things like chat should be to be useful
for it's it's completely clear that uh
for example cleaning up slightly messy
English kind of turn these notes into
less flowing text that's a clear kind of
thing that it's likely to be good at
um I think uh the um
uh sort of uh you know I I kind of I'm
looking forward to training one of these
things on on the many millions of emails
that I've collected over the past few
decades and uh I probably will get to
the point where I can generate an email
based on just a few words of notes and
it's kind of like what I might do
um if I'm asking somebody else to send
back a response to something I'd write a
few notes and then say turn this into an
actual email that you can send
um and uh so I
think I'll be able to automate a large
part of that process now the interesting
question is what will the footer say
um you know I I've had a footer for
things for for emails that I might send
that were dictated to a phone I've I've
had a footer for years that basically
says this was you know I don't remember
what it says anymore but basically says
this was dictated because the fact that
if you know it was dictated uh then if
there's some completely crazy word in
there you kind of have an idea why there
was a completely crazy word in there and
it doesn't seem as as um it's not as
incomprehensible and so similarly what
there's there's no doubt be a footer
saying you know this was um uh you know
this was generated by an AI it's just
like
back in the day
when uh
people used to have typewritten letters
and they would have somebody would have
their assistant type the letter and then
they would have a little notation at the
bottom that was indicated that the the
letter was really sometimes typed by
sometimes written by the assistant
um and uh you know it sort of be a
notation at the bottom that indicated
that and I think that's the kind of
thing we're going to have to invent the
conventions for for sort of AI assisted
AI written AI first AI second
um type type pieces of text
um
the uh
let's see
um
a comments here from Christopher about
generative images
needing to be able to recycle its uh
output for incremental Improvement yeah
I mean you know what one one can
certainly indicate this is an area that
one likes the scenario one doesn't like
regenerate the area you like you don't
like Etc et cetera et cetera and that is
providing additional training for these
systems and in fact in you know in the
case of chat GPT my understanding is
that there was a bunch of sort of
reinforcement learning once the thing
was basically running then there were a
bunch of people who were like uh looking
at chats that it generated and saying I
don't like this piece I don't like that
piece that part is great etc etc et
cetera and I think you know when when
chat GPT ends up having a very definite
point of view about some controversial
Topic in the world
um some part of that has no doubt the
results of that last stage of of of
training that was associated with having
humans actually look at these uh sort of
chats and and poking at um those
particular kinds of things rather than
the big massive training that came from
the web uh where where it's kind of I
mean there may be all sorts of all kinds
of crazy controversial things associated
with the massive material on the web but
I think the more obvious ones will come
from the actual uh sort of reinforcement
learning stuff that came sort of closer
to the end of the process
uh
how's it coming here from Krista chat
GPT will edit your emails into
publishable books okay so you know I'm
trying to work out what I'm actually I'm
actually going to train one of these
things the first estimate I have is that
I have 15 million words of email that I
have that I've written that um I have in
my archives and uh in terms of things
like even these live streams and other
kinds of things I've done uh in the last
just couple of years there's seven
million words of um of me yakking about
different kinds of things so that's a
reasonably decent number of reasonably
decent amount of training data
um and uh I suspect from that training
data it will be possible to make
something that will at least locally
be you know be able to generate text
rather like me and um uh whether you
know I've seen somebody sent me a a
complete book on some particular topic
written by chat GPT in the last few
weeks it's a little bit Bland it's a
little bit kind of um same old same old
on every page and it's kind of like you
know I can imagine books like that uh
that well I mean I've seen books that
are sort of formulatically written for
like decades people have had these
things where they're sort of computer
generated books I know there's a series
of these things thousands of them that
were about um various kinds of data
where people just sort of formulate it
like somebody just formulatically
produced all these books I think it kind
of dull I mean it's it's this same um I
mean I would say that track GPT does
better because it keeps on injecting
kind of these random facts about the
world sometimes they're true sometimes
they're not true
um but it kind of juices things up a bit
rather than just the pure recitation of
fact fact
um
the uh
uh those spare parts is coming in the
ass chat to me about what kind of human
filtering was used to limit its output
it gives interesting answers I I think
I've tried that I think it wasn't very
good at self self answering but you know
it changes every day
um
and uh
okay there's a comment from Jr here can
you please do a live chat GPT coding
session live stream that'd be fun
actually and I'm almost in a position to
be able to do that
uh
let's see oh is asking what are some of
the most interesting prompts you've come
up with that can Aid in everyday life
I mean I've been having fun putting in
all kinds of weird prompts and trying to
understand the science of what's going
on is there anything actually useful to
me
that I have put in I mean you know
thankfully I'm not a person who
typically has to write a lot of uh just
you know text for the sake of text you
know I'm not doing
I don't know some kind of compliance
filings I'm not doing some kind of legal
thing I'm not sending in you know uh
sort of uh you know just just sort of
things where you need I mean I sort of
uh you know I I kind of feel a little
bit sorry for people who have to receive
you know I don't know what they are you
know things coming in to complaint
bureaus or this or that or the other
where you know those things are going to
be machine generated and people can just
generate gazillions of these things
um and by the way to this point about
whether it will be detect or what's
machine generated the answer is
ultimately no it's going to be a sort of
arms race of oh there'll be detectors
for this and that oh there's a new
system uh that is um
uh that's kind of um uh you know that
evades that particular detector and so
on I think one of the issues is the
current chat gbt has 175 billion uh
parameters in it it's pretty big system
and it took I don't know some faction of
a year to train I think
um and uh it's um you know it's it's a
fairly big thing it was fairly expensive
to train Etc et cetera et cetera
um there's sort of that in a sense is a
protection against kind of the the
rapidly looping arms race of oh we'll
make a detector oh we'll make a new
system Etc et cetera et cetera but I
think that whatever difficulty there is
you know this was a this was a high wire
act for now but it won't stay such a
high wire act I mean you'll see probably
even the next few weeks you'll see other
companies coming out with uh things that
are sort of somewhat like chat GPT
they've been attempts before chat GPT
was a better piece of engineering than
the previous ones uh and uh and you know
didn't fall into some of the some of the
messy traps that that had existed before
um but you know I think this is a this
is the kind of thing where uh uh the the
difficulty of producing a system like
this
um will will decrease and that will mean
that this kind of arms race between the
is it AI is it not uh we'll we'll get
progressively more difficult and I think
it's kind of the kind of thing where uh
you have to expect that
um
uh you know that Society will adapt
rather than there will be a technical
solution I mean it's kind of like is
this a form letter or not
um and you know there was a time when
well even when I was a kid when you know
most letters were hand written kinds of
things or maybe typed on a typewriter
maybe you used carbon paper to get one
copy of them and you could very clearly
tell there was a copy of us to the
original to a point where you have Laser
Printers and so on in the 1980s and such
like where you can just churn out as
many copies as you want
um even with changes where you know you
say dear so-and-so as opposed to Dear
somebody else
um and you know each one of these things
you might have said oh everything will
collapse because people won't be able to
tell whether it was a letter
specifically for them or a formulator or
whatever else but somehow things adapt
to it and my guess is that will happen
here as well
um and uh you know I do think that in a
sense the uh the fact that another thing
the writing of sort of generic text
has now sort of fallen into the
automatable domain
um in a sense every time one of these
things becomes automatable it makes one
the things that are sort of specific to
humans and that are require us to have
sort of our actual set of sort of human
defined goals and things like this that
aren't just generic that are specific to
a particular human or whatever else I
kind of think that that in some sense
enhances kind of the the value of
individual humans and so on to be to
know that oh this generic stuff it can
just be done automatically it's the
special stuff that uh that can't be and
that's kind of a a it kind of sets that
further apart
um than before
let's see nightmare comments I've used
chapter TBT to help me give me ideas for
movie scripts that's that's interesting
um you know I do think that
uh I I I suppose I've I've tried using
it a couple of times now as a sort of
generalized thesaurus so occasionally
I'll be like what's the right word for
that
um
and uh uh
you know and I'll use a thesaurus now an
online kind of machine learning based
thesaurus and this is kind of a
generalization of that and I can imagine
for things like making up potential
names for functions and more from
language I can imagine that it's useful
I tried it a couple of times it didn't
didn't wasn't super brilliant in the
times I tried it but um uh it seems like
it could go in the right direction there
uh
let's see
couldn't a false detector be used as a
way to make the output of track gbt
actually be coherent isn't the detector
just the necessary component for chat
GPT to learn from its mistakes
well yes it certainly helps you can
certainly make a training Loop where
this particular problem will be will be
resolved the issue is I don't think it's
realistic for a system with this kind of
architecture to ultimately learn like
how to do some complicated mathematics
style algorithm it's just not going to
do it there are things it can do you
know you you know I I think I Now
understand reasonably well sort of how
it works inside and it's a fine thing
and it's but it's you know it's this big
statistical mushy thing it's not
something where it's going to be able to
suddenly construct from those things a
um you know this this precise algorithm
for doing something
um it uh you know it has
it's
it can do a lot of stuff but it's it's
it's going to be always saying well I've
got my way of kind of thinking about and
approximating this and it's not going to
be this thing that is a sort of precise
computation that can build forever
um
so Gordon is asking how can a language
model be integrated with symbolic system
um well the I mean for example in
Wolfman Alpha we're doing natural
language understanding turning things
into our precise symbolic form one thing
that we've wanted to do for a long time
we've done many experiments with with
machine learning and maybe these large
language models will do it significantly
better is if you ask a question that is
pretty close to something worth an alpha
can deal with but but it needs a little
bit of transformation possibly using in
a sense Real World experience to make
that transformation we haven't been able
to do that and so in a sense wolf Marvel
with its natural language understanding
provides a big catchment area for things
that are sort of modified uh kind of
natural language questions so that's a
that's an example and what I think
you'll you'll see happen if you look at
Wolfman Alpha notebook Edition for
example where you're using natural
language input to Define a series of of
different operations so you do one
operation you take that result you do
another operation and so on I think
there are really interesting things that
can be done by being able to take those
operations and have them be uh kind of
textually defined and and for example we
can go even further than that and you
can say oh I'm I'm you know I'm trying
to understand some data from some
company or something and oh the company
has tons of Internal Documentation which
I can't be bothered to read but if I
were only to read it then I would
probably know that column seven of
database such and such is the number I
want if I am trying to compute this
and I can imagine that with uh kind of
GPT type technology
um the uh
that one can uh could read all that
material be able to ask the question uh
you know what column is is this in it
will be able to to correctly determine
that then one can use that precise fact
sort of catched caught by uh kind of a
Wolfram Alpha style natural language
understanding interface
um turn that into symbolic language and
then go off and actually uh compute with
it
now there's a much more extreme version
of this if it's true that there's some
kind of uh theory of thought that is
associated with these sort of patterns
of of semantic flow
um if that's the case one can extract
those kinds of Primitives of the kind of
theory of thought and make them into a
symbolic language one might say you know
something like logic where you have you
know syllogisms like like you know uh
all metamoral Socrates as a man
therefore Socrates is Mortal
um that sort of pattern which is a you
can think of as a linguistic pattern
initially
um that sort of pattern we encode in
logic we then extract the logic from
anything to do with words no Socrates no
Mortals
Etc it's just logic and then we build
this huge tower that takes us to a lot
of modern digital Computing just on the
basis of that kind of formal structure
now if there is a similar formal
structure that captures some essential
feature of kind of the flow of meaning
that that humans use then that's a thing
where we can expect to extract that sort
of essence of what's going on turn it
into something symbolic and have a kind
of a powerful way for developing
reasoning about however you think about
it things that involve meaning I mean
there are other examples than than logic
there there are quite a lot of other
examples where we've abstracted and a
lot of things we've done in building
World from language we've abstracted
from the the kind of the everyday usage
we're talking about I know things to do
with time or things to do with uh I
don't know all sorts of things about
sequences and so on we've abstracted
from those things made a formal
structure that is a kind of a a
formalization of some kind of everyday
type of thing and then we're we're um
we're going from there
um another thing I should say is that
thing we've been interested in for a
long time is code assistants but being
able to make uh more likely to be
correct more from language code we've
done a bunch of experiments so I will
see I think some ideas from large
language models are likely to be useful
for that I'm I'm more skeptical I think
I think making small fragments of code
uh describe linguistically which is what
we've been able to do for a long time
with Wolfman Alpha and so on is is
potentially fairly useful the thing
that's been proved very useful over the
last decade or so is being able to for
example describe entities in the world
that we can represent symbolically but
describe it in the natural language
that's been a very useful mechanism it's
been a little less useful to to explain
sort of program operational fragments
that way but maybe it will become more
useful as the size of fragments one can
deal with increases a bit
uh
that's us do you think the chat GPT is
over hyped
um
and comments that apparently Chomsky was
talking about 60 years he said we're on
the a verge of an AI Revolution I don't
know I think I I don't know I don't know
what level of hype chat GPT is really
getting it's a very interesting thing
it's it's another look it's a moment
where what used to be thought of as
purely human is now clearly automatable
and the previous iterations even chat
you know even gpt2 was much
significantly less convincing really not
that useful I wasn't that interested in
it you know it was really a surprise how
well and it's it's also a tribute to
some good engineering done on on track
GPT that it is you know it is it is
doing a it is usefully good now I think
you know people found when wolf malpha
first came out same type of thing it's
like oh my gosh it's not impossible to
do that I remember showing um I think I
told the story uh a couple of times in
in this uh live stream uh Forum but but
um uh uh when Wolfman Alpha came out in
2009 I I happened to run into person I
knew quite well and then Martin Minsky
who was a sort of long-time AI pioneer
and so I say Marvin does this we built
this thing it's a you know question
answering system and it's like you know
let me show it to you he looks at it for
about you know 15 seconds and then it's
like starts to talk about something
different
and um uh I said you know Marvin you
should look at this more carefully this
time it actually works
and so okay so try to type in some more
things in and you know after five or six
queries it's like oh my God it actually
works and then he's like super excited
and and you know telling everybody else
that the the event that we were at you
know you've got to look at this you've
got to look at this
so you know it's one of these things
where where um uh
there's this point at which things get
to be sort of humanly useful
and you know we got to that point we go
from alpha for this kind of um uh
question answering and um uh I guess
Mathematica got to that point back in
the day 30
four years five years ago now
um of uh you know people who thought oh
you had to do you know uh and that
initially kind of mathematical
computation that was a domain of humans
type of thing and um that there's this
whole series of different kinds of
things where it looked like that was
human only and then it was like no
actually there's a credible piece of
automation piece of AI that can do that
and this is the moment where that's
happened for essay like material
um and and other things like that
um now you know and and there are things
that you know this is a human interface
so to speak that is you know when when
you say
um I don't know
put in this you know describe this thing
to somebody you could say bullet point
bullet point bullet point you know
specific things but the person probably
wouldn't understand because they need
too much context and it's like you know
like it notes that I would make that
might turn into some I don't know piece
of mail that somebody writes somewhere
you know they've worked with me for a
long time and so my you know three
letter acronyms for things make sense to
them if I were to send those three
letter acronyms or whatever to um uh to
the you know to the final recipient of a
piece of mail hopeless they wouldn't
understand what I was talking about but
uh you know this is in a sense a piece
of human interface you know the human
starts off with some kind of prompt you
know write an essay about this and then
in terms of communicating another human
this contextualizes that and gives one
sort of the full blob of text and and
that um uh and that that's I think how
that's some
uh why that's useful and I I know I I
think it is a it's an important thing
and I think it may even tell on some
really quite fundamental things about
how thinking works and that's uh uh you
know that's that's sort of exciting okay
maybe one or two more things that I
actually have to go to um uh
let's see
um
William was asking instead of training
in text wouldn't training on sensors
that we use such as video and audio be
better I suspect that a model that can
predict the next video frame will be as
intelligent as a human video contains
text inside itself
um and so on yeah I mean the you know
there are attempts to predict you know
the next frame in the in a in a video
and that's um uh you know that will come
no doubt
um I don't know exactly what that will
be like but eventually it will be
um uh you know this video was made by an
AI you know we've clearly got to the
point where static images can be made
that are pretty interesting pretty uh
you know convincing that plenty of
images where you say this is a you know
an image of a face and it looks just
like a face but it isn't any particular
person's face it's um statistically
generated mashup of a large number of
faces
um yeah I think I think this is a um uh
this is a thing that happens now you
know I just want to say one one last
thing perhaps it's here which is does
one know when these things are going to
happen and the answer is no and even the
people who are building them don't know
when we built wolf malphite I didn't
know it was going to work I didn't know
how well it was going to work
um I I know that in the case of chat GPT
the same is true nobody knew how well
this was going to work and nobody knew
at what point the threshold would pass
the same was two is image identification
you know telling this is a picture of a
cat versus a dog and so on that was a
threshold that was passed around 2011.
um and similarly with uh speech to text
or with language translation there are
these thresholds that get passed and
nobody knows you know the people working
on these things the uh you know the you
know by the time they've done tests they
know but but um at the point where it's
just like we're going to put in another
four layers and we're going to increase
the length of these vectors and so on
and you know is that gonna is that gonna
finally do it nobody knows and it's it's
so so when you ask me how soon will we
be able to predict make a good video
automatically I don't know the answer
that I don't think anybody knows the
answer to that
um you know when it when it happens
we'll know it happens so to speak
um and uh you know as we as we sort of
keep pushing further
um you know it will eventually happen I
think that one like the text I'm I'm
surprised the text one happened now
you know I don't I didn't um uh based on
sort of the the progress of things that
came before it it did not look like it
was really close it looked like it was
pretty crummy still and and there was
this real jump that happened
um and uh uh you know that happened
going from tens of billions of um uh of
parameters in the model to hundreds of
billions of parameters in the model and
it's it's kind of a funny thing I mean
maybe it's because you know we all have
about 100 billion neurons maybe that's
not unrelated to this this fact I think
it's also
um the uh
um
uh the the thing that um
um
is is worth realizing is one thing chat
GPT continues to put nails in kind of
the the the uh the coffin of or
something is the idea that brains have
something completely un understandable
to us in them you know it's it's really
looking like uh you know with every
passing kind of AI achievement that
there's less and less that is oh gosh
brains you know dip deep into quantum
mechanics in ways that we completely
don't understand to achieve the kind of
thinking we achieve no it's something
that is really uh looks like it's very
representable the formal computational
level
um and it's really just the the size of
this of brains is is sufficient that um
uh that they do complicated things
um Barry is commenting here is the fact
that I do things like logo the
keystrokes I type and so on uh have the
expectation that I can feed it into an
AI and it'll understand how I think
about stuff and so on uh yes that
thought it certainly occurred to me over
the course of the last 30 third of a
century or so on that I've been
recording all the stuff about myself
I've certainly had this idea one day
I'll feed all this material into some
kind of AI system and it'll be about lot
of me so to speak I have to say I wasn't
thinking that was all that realistic
anytime soon and I was been kind of
thinking about training various language
models and so on on email and so on and
now I'm highly motivated to do that
because I think it's actually going to
work for some purposes
um and uh whether in what sense it will
be possible to kind of you know this
idea of deducing thought processes you
have to have a representation of those
thought processes to say well there's
all these bits and they're flapping
around in this way is not something that
is a sort of human narrative sort of
scientific type Theory that's something
where you're just saying the thing works
because it works so to speak the thing
works the way it works and you're not
abstracting from that something higher
level whether it's possible to abstract
something higher level and say oh the
way that I think is by making these
Connections In This Way Etc et cetera
interesting question whether whether
that's going to be possible I I will say
I think I've said this before that that
one of the things I will do expect is
that sort of as these large language
models and so on get even more uh large
scale although they've used most of the
training data that is readily available
by now and they have to sort of train on
what they're themselves doing and so on
at this point but um the um
uh the ability to make these kind of big
analogies between very different domains
of uh of of information and so on well I
think be another would be a thing that
comes you know oh I'm uh you know I'm
making this poetic or scientific analogy
between something that happens in
biology over here and something that
happens in economics over here for
example being able to make those
connections because you can kind of tell
the patterns of of what's going on are
the same I think that's something that
will come and it's something that will
be a bit shocking to us humans because
some of those things are pretty hard for
humans to do partly because humans just
don't know as much they tend to humans
know about something in a particular
domain not about across all these
domains and I think that that may be one
of the things that will be the most kind
of shocking to people is an ability for
for sort of the AIS to jump from domain
to domain and I think that's already
something where if you look at Wolfram
language and you look at what's
happening inside that
um you know a lot of things where we're
able to compute stuff if you're an
expert in that particular kind of thing
it's like how on Earth are you able to
compute these things well the answer is
because we're using a lot of different
domains of knowledge sort of all
connected together in a coherent way to
be able to do that computation
all right I should stop here
um thanks for those uh comments
questions and um maybe I should do a
specific one of these live streams about
generative Ai and so on since it seems
like there are a bunch of questions
about this
um and uh oh I noticed one comment here
Arc says I've used Chachi potato
Constructor 365-day nutrition plan and
they're just having their first
breakfast based on it
good luck
let's hope let's hope the uh we don't um
uh find out that um
um
uh
I hope not too many people do do too
many dramatic Things based on oh Chachi
BT told me to do this that will be an
interesting um uh
interesting excuse structure anyway all
right well uh thanks for joining me and
see you another time
bye for now